estos mapas se utilizaron para explicar
cómo una marejada de 9 m que acompañó el huracán Katrina
pudo inundar comunidades como la mía en el sur de Louisiana
y las comunidades de la costa de Mississippi y Alabama.
La tierra que estábamos perdiendo era nuestro amortiguador del mar.
Me ofrecí para interactuar con los gráficos de la pared,
y en un instante mi vida cambió por segunda vez en dos años.
La gráfica mostraba una pérdida masiva de tierras en el sur de Louisiana
y un mar invasor,
pero más específicamente, el gráfico mostraba la desaparición de mi comunidad
y muchas otras comunidades antes del final del siglo.
No estaba sola en la parte delantera de la sala.
Estaba allí con otros miembros de las comunidades al sur de Louisiana,
negros, nativos, pobres.
Pensamos que estábamos unidos por la recuperación de desastres temporal,
pero vimos que ahora nos unía la tarea imposible
de asegurar que nuestras comunidades no desparecieran
debido al aumento del nivel del mar provocado por cambio climático.
Amigos, vecinos, familiares, mi comunidad:
yo supuse que siempre estaría allí.
Tierra, árboles, marismas, pantanos;
supuse que siempre estarían allí, por haber estado allí miles de años.
Estaba equivocada.
Para entender lo que le pasaba a mi comunidad,
tenía que hablar con otras comunidades en todo el mundo.
Empecé en el sur de Louisiana con la Nación Unida de los Houma.
Hablé con defensores de los jóvenes en Shishmaref, Alaska.
Hablé con pescadoras en la costa de Vietnam,
con defensores de justicia en Fiji,
con nuevas generaciones de líderes
de las culturas antiguas del Estrecho de Torres.
Las comunidades que habían estado ahí durante miles de años
estaban sufriendo el mismo destino,
y todos contemplábamos cómo íbamos a sobrevivir los próximos 50.
A finales del siglo siguiente,
se predice que más de 180 millones de personas
se verán desplazadas por cambio climático,
y en el sur de Louisiana,
aquellos que pueden permitirse el lujo de hacerlo, ya se están marchando.
Se están marchando porque el sur de Louisiana se pierde tierra
a una de las velocidades más altas del planeta.
La desaparición es lo que mi comunidad pantano
tiene en común con otras comunidades costeras.
Contra la desaparición están luchando las comunidades de todo el mundo
a medida que somos conscientes del impacto real del cambio climático.
He pasado los últimos 14 años abogando a favor de las comunidades
afectadas directamente por la crisis climática.
Estas comunidades están luchando contra la discriminación
mientras se recuperan de los desastres del clima,
y también tratan de equilibrar el desplazamiento masivo de personas
con un influjo en los demás
que ven la oportunidad de comenzar de nuevo.
Desde 2005 a las personas las han llamado "refugiadas"
cuando se ven desplazadas por el desastre climático,
incluso cuando no cruzan las fronteras internacionales.
Estos términos se usan de manera abusiva,
destinados a identificar al otro,
a la víctima,
a la persona que se supone que no debe estar ahí.
Estos términos son barreras
para la recuperación económica,
para la integración social
y para la curación requerida de la crisis climática y trauma climático.
Las palabras importan.
También importa la forma como tratamos a las personas que cruzan fronteras.
Hay que preocuparse por cómo las personas que cruzan fronteras hoy
son tratadas al buscar refugio y seguridad
por ninguna otra razón que la que podrían tener Uds. o alguien que amen
que necesite ejercer su derecho humano a migrar
en un futuro cercano.
Hay que empezar a prepararse para la migración global de hoy.
Es una realidad ahora.
Nuestras ciudades y comunidades no están preparadas.
De hecho, nuestros sistemas económico y social
solo se preparan para hacer beneficio fuera de las personas que migran.
Esto causará fases de gentrificación climática,
y también penalizará el movimiento de personas,
generalmente mediante la explotación de la mano de obra
y por lo general mediante la penalización.
La gentrificación climática que ocurre en previsión de aumento del nivel del mar
es lo que estamos viendo en lugares como Miami,
donde las comunidades que se mantenían en la línea de costa
ahora están ante un precio desfasado del terreno elevado
donde se habían asentado originalmente
conforme la gente se marcha lejos de la costa.
Estas personas se mudan obligadas a trasladarse lejos,
lejos de los sistemas sociales y económicos que necesitan para sobrevivir.
La gentrificación climática también sucede en las secuelas de un desastre climático.
Cuando grandes cantidades de personas dejen una ubicación
durante un tiempo indefinido,
veremos a los demás entrando en juego.
También vemos que sucede la gentrificación climática
cuando las viviendas dañadas son ahora "verde construido",
pero ahora tienen un valor más alto,
generalmente fuera del alcance de los negros, mulatos y pobres
que quieren volver a casa.
La diferencia de precio de los alquileres o la propiedad de una casa
es la diferencia entre ser capaz de ejercer tu derecho,
tu derecho a volver a casa como comunidad,
o ser forzado a ser reasentarse en otra parte
más resistente al clima,
menos costosa
y solo.
La crisis climática es un tema mucho más grande
que la reducción de las emisiones de CO2,
y es una conversación que no se reduce al tiempo atmosférico extremo.
Nos enfrentamos a un cambio en todos los aspectos de nuestra realidad global.
Y la migración climática es solo una pequeña parte,
pero va a generar un efecto dominó
en ambas ciudades costeras y en las ciudades del interior.
¿Así que qué hacemos?
Tengo algunas ideas.
(Risas)
En primer lugar, hay que replantear nuestra comprensión del problema.
El cambio climático no es el problema.
El cambio climático es el síntoma más horrible
de un sistema económico
que se ha construido para unos pocos
para extraer todos los valores preciosos de este planeta y a su gente,
desde nuestros recursos naturales
a los frutos de nuestro trabajo humano.
Este sistema ha creado esta crisis.
(Aplausos)
Debemos tener el valor de admitir que hemos usurpado demasiado.
No podemos cerrar los ojos ante el hecho
de que el mundo entero está pagando un precio
por el privilegio y la comodidad de solo unas pocas personas en el planeta.
Es hora de que hagamos cambios a nivel de la sociedad
de un sistema que incentiva el consumo
hasta el punto de desequilibrio global.
Nuestros sistemas de extracción sociales, políticos y económicos
debe transformarse en sistemas que regeneren la tierra
y avancen en la libertad humana a nivel mundial.
Es la arrogancia de pensar que la tecnología nos salvará.
Es el ego que nos hace pensar que podemos seguir
en este enfoque injusto y extractivo viviendo en este planeta
y sobrevivir.
(Aplausos)
Para sobrevivir a la siguiente fase de nuestra existencia humana,
tendremos que reestructurar nuestros sistemas sociales y económicos
para desarrollar nuestra capacidad de recuperación colectiva.
La reestructuración social debe ser hacia la restauración y reparación
de la tierra y de las comunidades que han sido desplazadas
criminalizadas por las generaciones.
Estas son las primeras líneas.
Aquí es donde empezamos.
Hay que crear una nueva actitud social para ver la migración como beneficio,
una necesidad para nuestra supervivencia global,
no como una amenaza para nuestro privilegio individual.
Resiliencia colectiva significa que ciudades en desarrollo puedan
recibir personas y proporcionar una vivienda,
alimentos, agua, atención sanitaria
y la libertad ante la excesiva intervención policial
para todo el mundo,
No importa quiénes sean,
no importa de dónde sean.
¿Qué pasaría si comenzamos con el plan de migración climática ahora?
Extendiéndose a ciudades en peligro que podrían ver esto como una oportunidad
de reconstruir una infraestructura social enraizada en la justicia y la equidad.
De hecho, podríamos poner dinero en los hospitales públicos
y prepararse
para lo que está por venir debido a la migración climática,
incluyendo el trauma que viene con la pérdida y la reubicación.
Podemos invertir más de nuestro tiempo en la justicia,
pero no puede hacerse para una ganancia temporal,
no puede ser de ayuda a los déficits presupuestarios,
tienen que ser para el cambio a largo plazo
y que tienen que ser como adelanto a la justicia.
Ya es posible, todos Uds.,
después del huracán Katrina,
universidades y escuelas secundarias de todo EE. UU. tomaron a los estudiantes
para ayudarles a terminar su semestre o su año sin perder el ritmo.
Aquellos estudiantes son ahora activos productivos en nuestra comunidad,
y esto es lo que nuestras comunidades, nuestras empresas y nuestras instituciones
necesitan para estar preparados por ahora.
El tiempo es ahora.
Así que a medida que replanteamos el problema de manera más veraz
y reestructuramos nuestros sistemas sociales de manera más justa,
todo lo que queda es para reindigenizarnos nosotros mismos
y para evocar un poder de la clase más antigua.
Esto necesariamente significa que debemos aprender a seguir,
no a fracturar, no a romantizar, no a descartar
el liderazgo y los conocimientos tradicionales
de un lugar local en particular.
Significa que debemos comprometernos con las normas de equidad ecológica,
la justicia climática y los derechos humanos
como base, un estándar de base,
un punto de partida,
para que nuestra nueva sociedad pueda seguir.
Todo esto nos obliga a reconocer un poder mayor que nosotros mismos
y una vida más larga que la que vamos a vivir.
Nos obliga a creer en las cosas que por ser lo suficientemente privilegiados
no tenemos que vivirlas.
Hay que respetar los derechos de la naturaleza.
Hay que avanzar en los derechos humanos para todos.
Debemos transformar
la sociedad individualista de un solo uso,
en una humanidad colectiva a largo plazo,
o de lo contrario no vamos a logarlo.
Debemos ver que incluso el mejor de nosotros está enredado
en un sistema injusto. Y hay que reconocer
que la única forma en que vamos a sobrevivir
es imaginando
cómo llegar a una liberación compartida juntos.
La buena noticia es que
descendemos de gente poderosa.
Descendemos de aquellos que, de una forma u otra,
han sobrevivido hasta ahora para estar aquí presentes.
Esta es una razón suficiente para luchar.
Y aprendan de su amiga del sur de Louisiana,
que esas peleas más difíciles son los que celebrarán.
Elijamos hacer hermosa esta nueva fase de nuestra existencia planetaria,
y mientras lo hacemos,
hagamos que sea justo y equitativo para todos.
Podemos hacer esto, todos nosotros.
Podemos hacerlo,
porque debemos hacerlo.
Debemos, pues de lo contrario perderemos nuestro planeta
y nos perderemos.
El trabajo comienza aquí.
El trabajo comienza juntos.
Esta es mi oferta.
Gracias por tenerme con Uds.
(Aplausos)